and I don't know how Batman does it it
is super scary up here hey will you grab
the binoculars they're in my stakeout
bag your stakeout bag is 98% nuts
I get snacky besides and that's her
super healthy they're like 0% fat Jake
that's not true at all it's actually the
opposite what that nut vendor lied to me
I think a pigeon just flew out of your
car yeah the windows don't exactly roll
up the car's a piece of crap why do you
love it so much you really want to know
I was two days out of the Academy super
nervous saw this guy run out of a bodega
clutching a bunch of cash so I pursued
him on foot 11 blocks finally catch him
cuff him throw him up against that car
turned out there was a for sale sign in
the window and it being the best day of
my life
I bought it thus began the debt crushing
debt you do know me yep only if you
throw it ready right hmm nice ready
[Applause]
what are you doing I'm trying to catch
it in your nose I got it I got it I got
it huh
it's holt keep practicing okay Peralta
oh good news Peralta I found someone
from the night shift to relieve you on
your stakeout Oh still make Times Square
um you know captain hold off on the
relief team we're already here
plus I'm curious to see what happens
okay it's your call way too hot what
just checking in how you doing any
progress yep watch the key is volume I
see that so be honest if you'd won the
bet where you're really gonna destroy my
car now I was gonna drive it so I could
learn stick I would would have been like
okay there's our guys what's the play
here just follow my lead
give me the ring there give me some nuts
I'm snacky all right fine darling I'll
ask him well that make you happy excuse
me sir Oh what kind of busy here yeah my
girlfriend here thinks were lost no I
know were lost I think he's an idiot
idiot you know why we're out here in the
middle of the night Susan I was gonna
propose to you and the Brooklyn Bridge
where we met Rockland Bridge we met on
the Manhattan Bridge you know what this
is over say goodbye to the ring and
everything it represents you hey hey
stop yelling no one talks to Susan like
that and you know what on the ground
nice work you two
I'm sad y'all arresting me I gotta say
I'm glad he's back together
[Music]
you